Hello. This is Six Minute
English from BBC
Learning English.
I'm Neil.
And I'm Beth.
Do you have a bank account,
Beth or, like my grandparents,
do you keep your money
under the mattress?
Sure, I have a bank account with one
of the big high street banks.
Yes. Me too. But do you know exactly
what your money's being used for?
Is it helping fight climate change
or polluting the planet?
Our money doesn't just sit there
in the bank.
It's invested
to fund other businesses,
some of which are far
from environmentally friendly.
So, do you know if your money is funding
dirty practices like oil drilling?
No, I don't.
I have to admit I'm very green
about money, and I don't mean
green as an environmentally friendly,
I mean green as in ignorant
or naive. In this programme,
we'll be discussing ways in which our
money can help protect the environment
and, as usual, we'll be learning
some useful new vocabulary as well.
Great. But first
I have a question for you, Beth.
As the climate crisis worsens,
people are making changes
in their lives to help.
For example by driving less
or cycling more.
One of the
most effective things to do is
be smart about investing your money.
So, according to the campaign
Make My Money Matter,
which of the following is the best
way to fight climate change? Is it:
A. to stop eating meat, B. to stop
flying or C. to change your pension?
I'll guess
it's changing your pension.
OK, Beth. I'll reveal the answer
later in the programme. Concerns
about how banks invest our money
led to the UK's first
environmentally sustainable bank,
Triodos, which opened in Bristol in 2012.
John Fleetwood, who has worked
in sustainable investing for decades,
thinks public interest in ethical banks
has ballooned in the last few years,
as he told BBC
Radio 4 programme,
Costing the Earth.
You know, it was always viewed,
I think, as a niche thing.
Something for those that had
very clear views on the world,
social views.
That's now broadened hugely
and there's great concern
about greenwashing.
So, who's jumping on the bandwagon?
That's a huge concern
amongst investors.
So what I'm doing is to tackle that
and actually to say,
OK, which are the funds that
are actually making a positive social
and environmental impact?
Ethical banks used
to be considered niche –
interesting or appealing
only to a small number of people.
But as environmentally responsible
investing increased, banks started jumping
on the bandwagon, an idiom meaning
to become involved in an activity
because it's popular, and not
because you're really interested
in it. As a result,
some banks have been accused
of greenwashing,
attempting to appear
environmentally friendly
without actually doing anything
serious to protect the environment.
But remember,
banks rely on customers' money and
are likely to change their behaviour
when customers threaten
to take their money elsewhere.
This idea inspired British film director
Richard Curtis to start his campaign,
Make My Money Matter,
On TV, Richard has raised millions
of pounds for
the BBC's charity, Comic Relief.
But even he was surprised by
the amount of money saved by doing
one simple thing – moving your pension
to an environmentally-sustainable fund.
And, as Richard told BBC
Radio 4 programme, Costing
the Earth,
he was even encouraged by former
governor of the Bank of England,
Mark Carney.
You know,
when I started this, everyone said,
well, you know all the mechanisms
and all the accounting and all the
transparency isn't quite there yet.
But Mark Carney said
to me, 'go for it',
because it will be the more
that people become interested,
the more transparent companies
will have to be, the more examples
they'll give you of good things that
you're investing in. So that, as it were,
it will get better
the more the spotlight is put on
exactly what an ethical
or sustainable pension is doing.
The more
people demand
responsible pensions,
the more banks need
to be transparent,
meaning open and honest
about their investments.
This in turn puts the spotlight
on how pension funds are being used,
for example, whether they support
large oil corporations
or renewable energy companies.
To put the spotlight on something
means to attract attention
to it, usually to share information
about something bad.
Luckily, the customer
is always right
and by managing our money
ethically, we can all help
a little. I think
it's time to reveal the answer
to your question
about the most effective way to fight
climate change, Neil.
I said it was by
moving your pension into ethical
investments. Which was...
the correct answer!
In fact, changing your pension
is thought to be 21 times
more effective than avoiding meat
and stopping flying put together.
OK, let's recap the vocabulary
we have learned from this programme
starting with green –
an adjective with several meanings,
one of which is naive or
inexperienced. A niche
interest appeals only
to a small number of people.
Greenwashing
describes attempts by a business to
seem more environmentally friendly
than they really are.
The idiom
jump on the bandwagon means
become involved in an activity
because it's popular
and likely to succeed,
not because you're really interested in
it. When a business is transparent,
it's easy to see how it works
because it's open and honest,
without hidden secrets.
And finally,
the phrase to put the spotlight
on something means to
draw attention to it.
Once again, our six minutes are up.
Join us again soon for more useful
vocabulary here at Six Minute
English. Bye for now!
Goodbye.